in this video we'll talk about lines and
signs Line Stands for long interspersed
nuclear elements whereas sine stands for
short interspersed nuclear elements
these are actually transposons in this
video we would learn their functions and
why they are even relevant we would also
look at their features
signs and lines are short and long
interspersed retro transposable Elements
which are one category of transposons
which transpose from one region to the
other region using RNA as an
intermediate
lines and signs are poly a retro
transposons which are different from the
retroviral retrotransposons and it lacks
the inverted terminal repeats
lines and signs are found in almost all
eukaryotes in fact they comprises 34
percent of the eukaryotic genome lines
are autonomous retroelements that means
they code for their own uh
the reverse transcript is enzyme whereas
signs are actually dependent they can't
code for the enzyme itself they are
dependent on the line derived enzymes as
the name suggests lines are much bigger
compared to the signs Mouse lines are
actually bigger than 6 kilobase pairs
whereas in human signs or short in
interspersed nuclear elements are
somewhere ranging from 200 base pairs to
400 base pairs now let's look at the
features of line in bit more details at
a first glance they look like protein
coding genes they have five Prime utr
three prime utr
and they don't have inverted terminal
repeats though
so Phi Prime and you three prime utrs
are adjacent to uh
poly a uh site which is characteristic
of any protein coding Gene because mrnas
has poly adenylation sites right
the orf2 codes for two important protein
first protein encodes for a RNA binding
protein and the second one encodes for
reverse transcriptase and endonuclease
activity containing protein both these
rf2 products are important for the
transposition reaction
so let's see uh how this thing happens
so lines
codes for
this particular protein with Indo and
reverse transcriptase activity that can
be also required for science for a
stable genomic integration that means
signs are totally dependent on lines
lines are autonomous signs are
non-autonomous
signs are similar to lines but they are
shorter simpler and
they are almost totally dependent on
lines
let's see how lines or signs get
integrated into the genome how these
transposons can hop from one region to
another
so this is a line
so generally they can be transcribed
with the RNA poly2
so RNA Paul 2 transcribes them and forms
the line mRNA so line mRNA is very
peculiar like a normal mRNA found in the
cytoplasm
so this basically
kind of like similar to any other
protein code in genes mRNA it has a 5
Prime utr three prime utr it has a
polyartenylation site
but what if two derived proteins
immediately bind to the line mRNA
and it forms a complex this complex
guide the further steps in the process
of integration
so this complex escort stem into T reach
region in the Target DNA
it forms a at hybrid so RNA DNA hybrid
in a t reach region eventually the first
strand synthesis takes place with the
help of these reverse transcriptase
containing activity reverse transcript
is activity containing enzyme eventually
the second strand synthesis also takes
place and ultimately DNA joining and
repair occurs that allows these lines or
these kind of transposons to get
integrated into the genome so the mode
of transposition is very different from
DNA based transposons or even retroviral
retrotransposons if you want to learn
more about them you can click on the
link in the I button
but here is a problem
how does line selectively take the line
mRNA or line sequence and put it in
other place of the genome I mean these
mRNA intermediates are very similar and
it is similar to any random mRNA let's
say mRNA for Gen X
so how does line make sure it doesn't
translocate Gene X's mRNA instead of its
own
I mean the proteins that are encoded by
orf2 can bind to both these mrnas
in theory but in real life it has been
found that these over F2 derived
proteins has a higher binding Affinity
towards line mRNA
as soon as they are synthesized because
there are specific sequences in the line
mRNA that brings out that Affinity
context
and thereby rarely a random transcript
is getting integrated into a random
region of the genome it happens it's not
totally impossible but the occurrence is
really rare
so let's talk about the functions of
lines and signs like any other
transposons they can regulate plethora
of things it can have mutagenic effect
so basically it can hop into a
particular or or if of a particular Gene
and disrupt that Gene that's possible
there could be epigenetic silencing of a
particular Gene these lines can also be
a site for long non-coding RNA Recent
research suggests that
they can also act like an enhancer
thereby regulating the gene expression
especially signs are known for their
roles in gene expression and modulating
them
so I hope that was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can get the notes in my Facebook page
follow us on Instagram support us via
super thanks and see you in next video